please rise
and spend over 40 hours of your work
week at work so why not invest in the
best wear your glasses make sure that
you're wearing them important feel like
the best employee you can be
what did you guys think about Game of
Thrones last night I think the
Lannisters are really in Sarah um yeah
it was pretty good yeah I liked it a
plush mark I just need to go bathroom
you got train one leaving the station
traveling west at 50 miles per hour
train to lose the station traveling West
95 kilometers per hour Mick you're gonna
love this place it's only 1,200 a month
we've got a laundry out back the
neighbors are awesome we've got a pool
it's on the third floor so let's check
it out
coming up will you play us something
okay okay I'll play a little something
yeah something you might recognise no I
was I was sending a text
here's your scratch paper don't forget
to show your work thank you if you don't
have any inner peace just imagine
somebody else's and cat photos just 60
it's double 30s huge chunks
paint your cubicle this guy went with
blue yeah I just need to dissect this
frog by lunch boss wants us to find the
spleen and the pancreas if you don't
mind cool why would I load why would I
mind
I don't know part of me wants to do this
you